like a fractal
emerging
and then turning around and asking
what am i
[Laughter]
a fractal emerges
and turns around and asks
what am i
that's what this is
unique firework
fractals that are beautiful
in their own unique individuated
artistic
expressionary ways
taking on all of these different
combinations of form
and beauty for us to
be in awe at
but that very first question
a secretion
of infinity
arising as a fractal
turning around on itself
and wondering what am i
that's what this is
in all of the seeking externally
oh i must
achieve this goal get this
substance this experience this
relationship
and then i will be happy
disastrous i am a finite
body disastrous
the only way to not be
disastrous is to recognize your true
nature
ananda truth consciousness bliss
infinity fractaling itself endlessly
infinity fractaling itself
endlessly you are that
infinity fractaling endlessly
infinity fractaling endlessly
that is what you are
that is what we are
[Music]
look at earth it's a fractal
look at all of its secretions they are
all fractals look at the universe they
are fractals look at the neurons in your
brain they are fractals
it is all fractals
infinity source expressing itself
forever forever ever
forever ever fractals
you are a secretion
turn inward go all the way with the
question
who am i what am i
what is my source
go all the way and come to the answer
that all of the metaphysicians
that all of the yogi's
have come to
which is that i am that
i am infinity i am source
i am that expressing itself that is what
i
am that is what you are that is what we
all are
we are that tatvam
asi i and my father are
one john 10 30.
you are that i am that we are that
endless fractaling endless fractaling
eternally
forever forever ever forever ever
that's what this is
you bring peace and happiness and joy
as your nature to
the dreamed creation designs
you bring peace happiness and joy
you don't extract peace happiness and
joy
from the dream creation design
how many different possible combinations
can you imagine endless infinite
you'll never come to the end of
combinations
ever ever
forever playing forever dancing
forever creating infinite creation
recognize that as home that is home that
is
you that is your nature
that is it that is what all of the great
mystic traditions point at
the diamond is already around our necks
it's just that we're not sensitive or
subtle enough
to recognize that this
is eternally fractally
expressing itself all
possibilities all creations
you are a secretion of that
turning back on itself and wondering
who am i why am i here
you're in a you're a creative emergent
property infinitely expressing itself
you'll never come to the end of that
you are expressing yourself creatively
forever and you are a property of that
identify yourself with the source
identify yourself
with infinity expressing itself do not
identify yourself with the body
do not identify yourself with the body
stop immediately identifying yourself
with the body with the form
stop
stop identifying yourself with form
stop you are the absolute that
expresses the form
you are the absolute that expresses the
form
you are that that is you
you are that which eternally
secretes the creative combinations
endlessly
you are not the body you are not the
form
it's so funny
[Laughter]
oh it's unbelievably funny
the cosmic joke
the cosmic play the cosmic dance
it's unbelievably hilarious
and we just go and seek and seek
and seek and seek
from room to room looking for the
diamond that's already around our neck
we are infinity expressing itself we are
source expressing itself eternally
endless combinations are possible we are
that
we are that i love you
i adore you recognize yourself as that
infinite secretion baby infinite
secretion you'll never
come to the end of all of the different
ways that you can paint a blank canvas
you will never come
to the end of all the ways that you can
arrange musical notes into a song
you will never come to the end of all of
the different ways
that you can make a movie you will never
come to the end of all of the different
ways that you can vibrate your vocal
cord
to make language to communicate you will
never come to the
end of all of the different ways that
you can put together ingredients
into food recipes
it's that simple stay
with the simplicity stay with the
explain like i'm five child-like
simplicity
and share that with other people
that is the key
just ask them those questions hey
how many different ways are there to
color a blank canvas
gee i don't know infinite
how many different ways can you put
musical notes into a song i don't know
infinite and the more that they do that
the more that they reflect themselves
you have to ask
the good questions you're basically
planting seeds
and watering the seeds by asking them
questions
that get them to reflect on their
own nature to recognize themselves as
infinity we don't tell
infinity that it's infinity we ask
a really good question that makes
infinity realize its own nature
that's the game play that game with
people
awaken them and then make it
easier for us to maximize our collective
prosperity
here
that's the key that's the utility from
the spiritual awakening is that it
becomes easier to maximize our
prosperity because we see
everything as the same infinity
expressing itself
therefore we aim as soon as possible
to maximize the basic needs of people
being met
that's the utility
recognize your own true nature as soon
as possible
it's the name of the game
and amnesia remembering
remembrance remember
who you are
remember where you are
infinity expressing itself
and while you're at it if you really
want the advanced
stuff those that are looking for a read
you can start with eckhart tolle power
of now
it's very good it's a very good starting
place
then when you're really ready
when you're really ready when you're
really really ready
i am that
that's right glad you love the book
that's it that's the key that is the key
it is been called the key for so long
now
so many simple easy ways to recognize
your true nature
i adore you all thank you so much
keep communicating the simple ways to
understand our true nature sharing that
namaste to you all i bow to the divine
[Music]
you